libertarians just want to take care of
themselves and not take care of other
people you must hate the poor you must
love the rich you must be a pacifist
they are different from what you are I
want everybody to die from tainted
liquor or from food poisoning for reason
I'm Justin Monticello I'm here in New
Hampshire for pork fest or the porcupine
freedom festival put on by the Free
State Project
it's an annual week-long gathering of
Liberty minded individuals from
anarchists to libertarians I'm here to
ask folks what's one thing you're tired
of hearing when you tell other people
your political beliefs sometimes people
say like things like Oh anarchists are
all violent without government Warlord's
will take over society it bothers me
because with government warlords have
already taken over Society my mom she
pretty much does ask why are you a
little bit tearing that was supposed to
be Democrats they're like normally black
people aren't limit areas but I'm like
ah some people are just way different
than others
being a Democrat just kind of a trapped
you know they tell you one thing and
they do something else
I really dislike when people say well
Venezuela didn't tell because it wasn't
real socialism
you know marijuana is evil how will
people build public roads without
government the taxes that you pay as a
business or price that he paid to be a
part of a civilized society I grew up in
the north of Mexico my parents are
cattle ranchers and no one maintained
the road no government did the local
ranchers got together decided to pool
their funds to hire a tractor to go pave
the road so who will build the roads
well I've already answered that question
in my own lifetime
[Music]
definitely I'm transitioning into a
crypto based company I'm really tired of
hearing all of people's for your excuses
government has effectively banned the
thing that I'm tired of hearing it's
maybe a plot of the dark event since
it's anonymous it can be used for like
bad thing people that say that the
bailouts that we did you know that these
banks were too big to fail the rich
don't pay for this stuff you know it's
it's regular people you know the people
that can basically least afford it
I shouldn't object to paying twenty six
thousand dollars a year in taxes to run
a small restaurant so that I can have
employees that can barely read
I want most tired of hearing is that I
don't care about the environment charity
just because I don't want government
doing anything about it small changes in
the amount of decentralization or
centralization changes how happy our
society is how healthier children are
how long we live that sort of thing I
actually care more than the person who's
not willing to question how they go
about accomplishing those goals I'd say
I'm maybe tired of a lack of openness
you know what are your philosophies
rather than your labels I know the only
thing that the universe really cares
about is how we treat each other using
coercive government just it's time to
move beyond that there's much less
harmful much more efficient ways of
doing that I mean I like being free
[Music]